oi meu nome é artur e eu gostar
o que você fazia quando tinha 9 ou 10
anos nós conversamos com algumas pessoas
e era bem diferente da nossa tempo você
imaginava que teria computadores na
escola imaginava usando e criando coisas
nós criamos jogos
nós programamos jogos ficando pra nós
com o projeto de educação compartilhada
onde aprendemos com o minecraft nosso
esquema agora é o escrete
o scratch é um jogo que usa comandos e
programação assim a gente aprende mais
rápido e melhor nosso raciocínio em
todas as matérias
todo mundo pode ter um jogo nós criamos
ensinamos nossos colegas
os jogos são a linguagem da gurizada de
hoje
a gente aprende várias coisas com os
jogos criaram jogo é mais legal ainda um
jogo divertido ensina a fazer fazendo e
desafia nós gostamos de aventura posou
escape e com isso nós gostamos de fazer
para aprender onde receberá as coisas
prontas é resolver os problemas através
de desafios
jogando juntos aprendemos juntos
isso faz a gente pensar e criar mais na
escola
falamos sobre o que gostamos de jogar a
gente pagar assuntos interessantes do
dia a dia para criar nosso jogo a gente
faz o que pensou do jogo e cria a gente
aprende muito melhor do que está lendo e
copiando de um livro
a galera da nossa cidade é curiosa e
gosta de aprender coisas diferentes
maneiras e radicais aprender assim é
mais legal a gente escolheu fazer um
jogo sobre meio ambiente os a nossa
criatividade aprender sobre a separação
do lixo por exemplo pode ser muito mais
top na frente do computador programando
ou jogando o game do que na sala de aula
copiando um texto jogar faz parte da
nossa vida
nós queremos jogar e aprender com
os professores pesquisas mostram que os
games no brasil tem perfil de
multiplataforma 74% jogam em mais de um
dispositivo o smart é o mais popular
depois vêm os computadores com 77% e os
consoles com 49% é que tentamos não sei
o que você está fazendo
mas tomara que seja tudo mais divertido
ele seja bem diferente
iniciamos como no bis para aprender
a gente tem que fazer e coletar
experiência e então escola desde o teu
like clique f5 e atualiza